J'aimerais aborder avec vous un sujet qui est très important pour moi un peu délicat ça fait longtemps que j'ai ça sur le coeur et
aujourd'hui je suis prêt à me livrer
j'aimerais vous parler de
des barbecues
le mec fait une vidéo sur les barbecues putain...
alors j'avais déjà fait une vidéo sur la raclette maintenant une vidéo sur des barbecues
J'ai l'impression que je suis clairement en train de me spécialiser dans la restauration.
je viens de faire mon premier barbecue de l'année et je trouve que d'un point de vue objectif
la phrase "et on se fait un barbec'?"
franchement elle met l'ambiance
Tout à coup y'a un truc qui se passe,  on envie d'appeler des potes, se mettre dans le jardin avec un peu de musique
on a envie de prendre l'apéro
sortir les parasols est aussi tout à coup on sait pas pourquoi mais tout le monde a le droit d'être un peu beauf
*C'est la merguez, merguez party !*
Quand on fait un barbecue tout le monde met la main à la pâte
c'est un truc collectif, mais on dirait que la répartition des rôles se fait par ordre de virilité
Toi, tu t'occupes du feu,
toi tu t'occupes du charbon
Toi tu t'occupes de la viande
Et Norman tu peux mettre les assiettes en carton...STP
lol
Yes, yes ça c'est mon rôle ça
Un vrai barbecue réussi, c'est jamais sans ce petit moment, cette petite minute
de guêpe de petites putes de guêpes même
elles arrivent en groupe à sont toutes là, je sais pas on dirait qu'elles vont nous (hagale?)
et ya toujours ce mec qui est là,
pour faire son malin et t'expliquer quelle attitude faut adopter quand il y a une guêpe autour de toi
AAh, j'ai une guêpe sur la main !!
alors si tu bouges pas, elle ne te pique pas
Aaah elle m'a piqué !
Bon bah ça n'a pas marché
dès que les beaux jours arrivent le mec qui possède un barbecue dans son jardin
tout à coup comme par hasard c'est le pote de tout le monde
je me disais c'est marrant parce que de septembre à juin vous m'avez pas appelé
bah non c'est les aléas de la vie c'est tout, ouais c'est ça c'est la vie c'est comme ça mon petit pote
t'as pas une petite saucisse à dépanner là?
et je me demandais, ta piscine, tu l'as toujours ou pas?
Alors évidemment pour allumer le feu
tout le monde se croit plus malin que l'autre, tout le monde ramène sa petite technique nul comme s'ils avaient allumé des feux toute sa vie
Je sais allumer un feu, j'ai été scout : tu tournes très vite ça peut prendre quelques minutes
on dirait pas mais ça chauffe.. Ah il y a un peu de fumée
Ah non, c'est de la poussière
ça marchait mieux à l'époque
et après et après tu prends un briquet
Tu ventiles le feu au max et après la merguez elle est nickel
Bon... Ça l'a éteint...
Alors c'est un peu de la triche certes mais moi j'utilise juste un ou deux petits allume-feu
Ah la nature...
Sentez, sentez, sentez
quand tu fais un barbecue c'est le seul moment de ta vie ou la viande elle tombe dans les braises et les cendres dessus
elle tombe par terre elle est dégueulasse et tout le monde s'en fout
désolé celle ci elle est tombée par terre il ya du gazon de la terre, des poils de chien, dessus
Qui la veut?
Moi je suis chaud, je suis chaud! Moi j'aime trop j'aime trop quand c'est comme la!!
alors rien débat qui est aussi inintéressant que pain au chocolat vs chocolatine,
Pourtant c'est dur, c'est :
Faut-il ou non piquer les saucisses?
Mais enfin Monsieur, arrêtez vos inepties, le français aime la merguez piquée, la merguez qui n'explose pas, la merguez en sécurité
N'importe quoi ma ptite dame, ils savent que quand on la pique la graisse coule!
justement on vient de recevoir les résultats des sondages et apparemment 100 % des français s'en battent les couilles de ce débat
ils aimeraient juste manger tranquillement.. A vous les studios
c'est vrai que ça demande du travail de faire le feu le charbon et tout mais franchement tout ça ça vaut vraiment le coup
quand on arrive à ce moment magique
C'est pas cuit !  - Non mais c'est immangeable il faut les recuire
Non mais t'es le roi de la saucisse ou t'es pas le roi de la saucisse?  - Tu veux qu'on attrape le ver solitaire?
le petit inconvénient peut-être quand tu faire un barbecue c'est que après... tu pues... tes vêtements sentent le carbonisé
-Laisse moi deviner, toi récemment tu as fait un barbecue
-Ah non moi je suis quelqu'un qui sent très fort
-Ah ouais, d'accord, c'est fort là, ouais
Les barbecues ça devient addictif t'en fait plein pendant tout l'été et quand l'été se termine il ya toujours un mec qui a pas compris
il veut continuer
allez c'est bon là, c'est que 2-3 gouttes, venez là
Bon, qui veut une chipo mouillée?
Alors oui, il existe des barbecues électriques d'intérieur
moi personnellement je suis pas totalement pour ce concept, je vais vous faire économiser un peu d'argent. Aussi bien que les barbecues d'intérieur il existe ceci
une poêle
10 euros ça fait tout
alors moi en ce moment je traverse une période où je mange de moins en moins de viande, hein, pour pleins de raisons
sauf que évidemment j'ai essayé de faire ça au moment où tout le monde se met à faire des putains de
barbecues qui tuent sa mère
mais c'est pas grave puisque les barbecues peuvent très bien être végétarien, vegan ou ce que vous voulez
Alors qu'est ce qu'on retient des barbecues?
Bah, c'est  ni les saucisses ni les guêpes
ce qu'on retient surtout qu'on passe un moment ensemble
la famille les proches les amis
merci beaucoup, thank you very much, merci d'être venus.
Yess j'ai actuellement une tâche sous l'aisselle j'en suis conscient YO C'EST LA TACHE! LES ABONNES VOUS ETES LA OU QUOI ?
hahaha, thank you very much. Y'en a aussi une deuxième sous le bras gauche. SALUT C'EST LA DEUXIEME TACHE, TU VEUX SENTIR?
Hahaha
Elles sont énormes elles s'appellent Pif et Hercule
bref bon appétit si vous avez aimé cette vidéo mettez un pouce en l'air
si vous avez apprécié mes potos comédiens qui jouent dedans n'hésitez pas à les voir leur travail je mets leur lien dans la description
et puis moi je m'en vais écrire ma prochaine vidéo sur la choucroute yes ciao